vous qui évoluez il y a encore quelques
jours auprès de la délégation de la
Commission européenne qui était arrivé à
Kiev c'est encore une nouvelle séquence
aujourd'hui qui est en train de se jouer
finalement à domicile Zelinski a fait le
déplacement en personne il y a un vrai
enjeu pour lui aujourd'hui oui alors
déjà il va figurer sur la photo de
famille qui se met en place vous le
voyez photos de Fanny traditionnelle à
27 des 27 chefs d'État et de
gouvernement avec les institutions
européennes où il va figurer bientôt et
ça c'est une façon de l'attraper de le
de lui dire bienvenue dans la famille
européenne c'était d'ailleurs les mots à
l'arrivée de Charles Michel bienvenue
chez vous bienvenue dans l'Union
européenne c'est vrai que cette
Ukraine en pleine guerre a bénéficié
d'une procédure tout à fait exprès pour
avoir une candidature à l'Union
européenne agrée depuis le mois de juin
bien qu'elle est d'énormes et soyons
honnêtes sur ce chapitre problème de
corruption qui ont touché jusqu'à son
ministre de la Défense de détournement
de fond de surfacture etc et donc c'est
une façon de montrer que concrètement on
inclus dans cette famille c'est une
façon aussi de de lui donner des gages
que cette adhésion aura bien lieu à
terme mais peut-être pas tout de suite
alors où elle est en train de se faire
en direct cette photo de famille
peut-être commenter l'image parce que ça
c'est une image qui va faire date on est
loin des visioconférences voilà là il
prend place au sein des dirigeants des
27 c'est très fort c'est on imagine que
les Russes sont en train de regarder
c'est très inhabituel pour un pays
candidat donc il a vraiment les honneurs
le tapis rouge du Conseil européen et
puis il faut savoir qu'aussi on sait un
petit peu chamailler pour être sur la
photo avec lui aujourd'hui les jours
précédents c'est vrai que être en
compagnie de volodimeersinski c'est une
façon de montrer le soutien de son
institution qui est bien réelle à
l'Ukraine alors Roberta mezzola a eu la
primeur
[Musique]
européen dans les bilatérales il y en
aura sans doute vous le dit mirzeninski
va rappeler l'importance de cette
armement parce qu'il redoute au 24
février date anniversaire de l'invasion
de son flanc est une grande offensive
russe et demande les armements les plus
modernes très vite mais les Européens
insistent qu'il faut avoir les bons
armements pas tous les chars par exemple
pas tous les avions mais seulement ceux
sur lesquels on arrive à former les
ukrainiens et qui servirontirablement à
quelque chose merci beaucoup Caroline
qu'on va retrouver un